I would advise anyone including myself
that any moment you are,
you understand your life is good.
Then everything that's led up to it was
worthwhile.
And the reason I say that,
it's not that I haven't laid mistake,
I'd made some glorious mistakes and I
suffered in my life for those mistakes.
But I'm sitting here talking to you this
morning and my world.
I am too concerned with the,
the,
the problems.
Uh,
then in trailer parks everywhere.
But in my personal world,
I couldn't be happier.
I have six kids.
They delight me thoroughly and they are
all very close with one another and our
family get togethers at the best thing
going in my life.
So I figure
if I can say that at this moment,
feel that at this moment it wouldn't
change anything that got me here.
You know,
all of the mistakes,
all the drama,
all of the bullshit that went on earlier
that so much of which I was responsible
for.
If the,
if the moment you're at is a great
moment and you're happy for who you are
at this moment,
that everything that got you here is
worthwhile because it's all gone.
That's yesterday.
The two,
two of the most important words I think,
uh,
are over in next.
When somebody is over,
it is over.
And then we're all onto the next and the
hammock in the middle between those two
words is what I think is meant by truly
living in the moment.
You know,
when I get it from this interview,
it's greatest was
there ain't anything I can do if I wish
to fix or change or I've done it next.
So I think being invested in next and
not the past,
it's best.